and you know that brings us to one of
the main issues that we've seen in the
Trump administration since day one
Donald Trump has made it clear that he
wants to absolutely gut the
Environmental Protection Agency and any
and all regulations put forth by the
Obama administration just this week
epa head scott pruett tells us that
we're gonna dismantle get rid of do away
with throw in the trash President
Obama's clean power rule which regulates
the amount of emissions that coal plants
and power plants can conspirators
different levels based on when the plant
was built etc etc but overall it was to
reduce or reduce our carbon emissions
helped prevent air pollution to an
extent and let Americans breathe easier
but now scott pruett
who made a name for himself back in
Oklahoma for constantly suing the FE PA
excuse me
decides we don't need that we don't need
people to be able to breathe clean air
we don't need corporations to be held
accountable for destruction of the
environment and destruction of human
health we don't need that
Scott Pruett tells us what we need to do
is end the war on coal the war on coal
Scott Pruett tells us he says that
repealing this clean power rule is
absolutely the end of the war on coal
coal country can come back they can
bounce back they're gonna be out there
making so much coal it's gonna it's
gonna blow your mind
well again reality doesn't match up to
Republican talking points it rarely does
the reason coal is dying in the United
States and all over the world is because
demand is falling demand has fallen in
some of the largest markets in the world
China and India and it's been that way
for several years I mean this is not
information that's been hidden from the
American public there are plenty of
articles and studies out there showing
that global demand for coal is declining
and that's why we have coal
company's going bankrupt left and right
two or three years ago cold CEOs
actually came out and admitted that this
so-called war on coal that they've been
talking about from the Obama
administration was a complete
fabrication from day one it never
existed and yet people like Mitch
McConnell and Scott Pruett and Donald
Trump have all come out and repeated
that same talking point that the
industry itself debunked years ago
saying that there was some kind of war
on coal I mean Trump during the campaign
promised co-workers he was gonna put
them back to work well you can't put
people back to work in an industry when
nobody wants to buy what you're selling
but they think or at least they claim
that repealing these regulations by
getting rid of these life-saving safety
standards that coal miners are gonna be
put back to work now let's be perfectly
honest here the administration doesn't
think that'll happen they do not they
know better they've seen the studies
they've created a lot of them what they
think however is that people in coal
country those out-of-work coal miners as
long as they believe it they're gonna
keep voting for these politicians
they're not gonna you know suddenly
switch over to be Democrats because
Republicans are always going to use that
talking point it's been proven time and
time again to actually be successful
with them but nothing's gonna bring the
coal industry back and to be honest we
don't need it back what we need to be
doing is investing in better forms of
renewable energy investing in our energy
infrastructure something that this
administration is unfortunately actually
trying to scale back reports earlier
this week showed that the Trump
administration was trying to scale back
or completely eliminate the subsidies
that we're giving to wind and solar so
there you have it folks that that's
where our priorities lie as a country
right now do everything we can for the
fossil fuel industry while leaving
American citizens to deal with the
pollution and trying to strangle from
the inside renewable energy
I'm fairing cousin sitting in for David
Pakman today on the
David Pakman show you can follow me on
Twitter at Baron balanced we'll be right
back